[Music]
so nice to see you both thank you thanks
for dressing up means I'm comfortable
with it means thank you thanks so much
to meet demi let's get started right
away what do you think of Simon's tight
t-shirts you know let's talk about this
yeah what's funny is we're trying to
reach to a younger demographic yes and I
just don't feel like we're gonna
accomplish that when he's showing more
cleavage than Brittany and I are yeah
what do you think is this something you
put a lot of thought into Simon show
more cleavage yeah I'm good thank you
okay well so am I I'm not showing any
cleavage this is a t-shirt I'm surprised
because normally you could like braid
your chest hair tell it to stop picking
on me but don't pick on him he's a kind
man who's never insulted anyone salad
you've said that you find demi lovato
annoying you have said that yes to too
many people you've said that to the
press she's here with you right now
let's have at it
would you say said yeah let's clear it
up you are very annoying Thanks how does
that how that we do all you give you a
bit of an hour
you're comfortable being with people
that annoy you
yeah I mean let's talk about Seacrest
we've got to talk about Seacrest yeah he
was really annoying yeah he was do you
feel at all responsible I mean you
created that man and now he's become
this juggernaut and you let him loose on
America you unleash two minutes your
fault are you guys still friends you
guys still hang out together uh we talk
occasionally what are you talking about
you were best pals used to get masseuses
and we're not together yes I used to
interview the two of you and you would
say you went to spars together and you
get those tables that we slide into each
other having a massage we may have gone
to us good question the side okay it
isn't me no but you're in this country
[Music]
we [ __ ] that one out about 200 years
ago
[Applause]
[Laughter]